pas parler de crise ordre est agile voit
pas une critique étrangers l'ancien
boxeur professionnel il est champion de
france il était champion de france des
lourds légers en 2007-2008 alors on va
voir la vidéo qui l'a fait connaître
malgré lui il nous a accordé une
interview christophe dettinger vous avez
vous dire ce que vous en pensez donc il
avait été filmé en train de boxer vous
le savez des forces de l'ordre est ce
que voulait revoir l'image
oui bon bah non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est bon alors c'est vrai qu'on a
du mal à revoir ces images un mineur à
tous prêts que je vais demander si vous
voulez les revoir ou pas donc il s'est
ensuite rendu à la police après avoir
fait une vidéo de mea culpa
il nous a donc accordé une interview
christophe dettinger il explique dans
cette vidéo pourquoi il a choisi de
s'exprimer dans balances ton post
regardez bon allez j'en ai ma famille
mes amis mon entourage et gens qui ont
pu le côtoyer quelques instants dans
savent très bien que c'est pas moi c'est
pas cette personne qui sont médiatisés
mais savent maintenant à des millions de
personnes ont vu environ les infos
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent que c'est
pour ça que je suis aujourd'hui s'en
cache pas voilà donc il il a voulu
s'exprimer alors eric naulleau vous avez
souhaité lui poser une question
par l'intermédiaire de notre journaliste
vous avez dit j'aimerais comprendre ce
qui s'est passé précisément pour qu'il
arrive à un tel acte de violence mais
moi j'aurais bien aimé qu'on voit toutes
les images parce qu'il y en a d'autres
encore plus choquante cette claque en à
un moment il ya une scène de lynchage où
ils s'acharnent à coupon là on a l'image
sur la pole ici la terre avec l'aide
d'autres personnes
écoutez moi c'est le problème c'est que
quand je vois que la première séquence
je me dis le type pète les plombs ça
arrive à tout le monde bon voilà la
deuxième séquence est à terre dont
j'aurais bien voulu oui savoir qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans sa tête au delà et
va écouter il aurait pas là ce jour là
c'était trop
c'était pas des casseurs qui était bien
on fait des gens du peuple et pas de
casseurs il n'y a pas de voyous y avait
rien on s'est tous fait gazer on s'est
fait matraquer j'ai vu cette violence
policière cette violence qui a été
extrême tout le monde se faire matraquer
et une personne au sol soit ce que je
faut se faire taper 7,7 trop j'ai réglé
une injustice en en créant une autre
vous avez vous a répondu qu'est ce que
oui on devrait tous oui non non juste
c'est dans cet écrit et bernard
violences depuis le début j'entends pas
de violence pas de violences doit du
respect qu'on ne parle pas de la
violence des deux bâle un petit peuple
fort qu on ne parle pas de la comptant
pas la 6e ne parle pas de la violence
des deux côtés 21 éborgné on en a parlé
on a parlé on en reparle
je suis fier de dire car ça ne convient
pas on en parle parce que souvent on a
considéré comme c'est un acte volontaire
légitime donc il aurait reproduit sans
foi mais ce que finalement avec le recul
dans le feu le regrette
ce que finalement il regrette ou pas son
acte la regarde où je ne regrette pas
d'avoir défendu cette dame j'aurais dû
juste pour pousser gendarmes m'ont
arrêté là c'est sûr ouais j'aurais dû
juste le pouce et mais toutes ces
violences qui sont faits j'ai joué tous
ses yeux et le renier ses mains ses
ennemis ces gens mutilés la violence à
la base des premières violences à bien
deux thématiquement moi je suis choqué
quand je suis devant mais télé ou quand
j'entends les gens mettre la violence
des gilet jaune à égalité de la violence
des forces de l'ordre moi aujourd'hui je
vois pas non je suis désolé
quand on parle de départ j'ai pourquoi
ça a dégénéré pourquoi il ya des bombes
lacrymogènes parce que vous avez vous
enfin je sais pas si tu étais dans cette
marge était juste sous le bon je suis
bien d'accord et tu pourras confirmé que
vous avez voulu sortir du parcours vous
avez aussi si vous avez raison
alors comme ça ce matin là effectivement
qu'il ya eu un blocage jessica j'ai vu
le parcours j'ai vu ce qui s'est passé
je me suis dit ils vont pas bloquer la
route la seule sortie c'était le pont on
a vu qu'ils commencent à fermer la route
j'ai dit [__] mais ils sont cons quoi
les et avait sept collègues sur le pont
lassalas a vraiment un souci de gestion
du matin de l'ancien président on veut
voir séquence avant la séquence pendant
la séquence après la séquence avant je
vois le cortège qui se fait bloquer
alors qu'on devait aller tout droit qui
savent pas c'est bien mais pas de casse
y avait rien ils ont bloqué la seule
sortie c'était le pont avec cette
collecte sur le pont cette collègue sais
tu de tes collègues sur le pont je me
suis dit sont complètement taré ils sont
complètement taré de fermer parce que
les sept collègues sur le pont si ça
part en couille puisqu'ils vont bloquer
ils vont risquer de tomber dans la scène
avec leur équipement ça donc je rassure
un peu donc c'était au lieu de
constituer isolé j'en fais quoi
bah ils ont tourné à droite puisque
c'était bloqué de partout alors on s'est
retrouvés et là je finis juste un
certain 27 collègues christophe a fait
ce qu'il a fait il fait son mea culpa et
10 kg ce qu'il a fait christophe quand
même moi je trouve que arrête quand il a
quand il tape sur le jeu demande une
chose il fait je demande une chose ah
non je vois moi je donne mon avis pas
dit quand je le vois taper à mains nues
sur un bouclier
est-ce que c'est plus grave ou moins
graves que le policier qui était en
train de tabasser qu une matraque à
terme une dame juste devant christophe
on s'échappe aux questions à milan mais
surtout c'est visible est posée ici on
s'est produit il ya une enquête qui est
ouverte du oui et justement ça que je
voulais donner m'a demandé d'où les
repris 1800 et maxime quand il sera tjrs
policier à terre tu peux pas tu en fais
ça c'est ridicule son jugement est
effectif depuis le début juste je dise à
1800 jugement c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est madame bélouve et qu'il l'a dit
sur la radio
meyer ou en fin de journée 1800 jugement
gilet jaune 1800 à venir il n'y a pas eu
d'attentât 174 donc en quête 10 gp n pas
une n'a encore abouti
ça fait pourtant mis 700 blessés graves
22e bornier cette main